(audience applauding)
- So, the season finale of
"Ted Lasso" is about to happen,
and I've heard it might be the end end.
Is it the end end?
- Well, I don't know, I mean
- We don't like
to be finite?
- Jason says it's like
the end of that three season arc?
- Oh, interesting.
- Yeah.
I mean I feel like trapping him
in a dungeon with a notepad and a pen.
- It's a good idea.
- And just going,
dude, what are you doing?
You can't step away from it.
The characters are so beloved,
and we all love it.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I would play her
when her teeth are falling out
in a retirement home
- Such a great character.
- sitting outside it with
mud splashing her, you know?
I would, I just want to see her through.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love her so much.
- I love the idea of that
though, of almost taking a show
(audience applauding)
and doing it in different,
almost how they do with Marvel.
You know what I'm saying?
You'd see different characters
and different things.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's a cool idea.
You all should do that,
- Bouncing off elsewhere.
- Jason.
- Yeah.
No, Jason.
Where's the camera?
Jason.
- (laughing) I love it you
went American for Jason.
- Jason.
(both laughing)